the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so last time we've seen the curl of
vector field with components m and n we
defined that to be n sub X minus M sub y
and we said this measures how far that
vector field is from being conservative
if the curl is 0 and if the field is
defined everywhere then it's going to be
conservative and so when I take a line
integral along a closed curve I don't
have to compute it I know it's going to
be 0 but now let's say that I have a
general vector field so the pure will
not be 0 and I still want to compute a
line integral along the closed curve
well I could compute it directly or
there's another way and that's what we
are going to see today so you know say
that I have a closed curve C and I want
to find the work so there's two options
one is direct calculation and the other
one is greens theorem
so range theorem is another way to avoid
calculating line integrals if we don't
want to so what does it say it says if
say if C is a closed curve and closing a
region R in the plane and I have to
insist see if it go counterclockwise and
if I have a vector field
let's defined and differentiable
everywhere not only on the curve C which
is what I need to define the line
integral but also on the region inside
then
the line integral for the work done
along C is actually equal to a double
integral over the region inside of curl
F da okay so that's the conclusion and
if you want me to write it in
coordinates maybe I should do that so
the line integral in terms of the
components that that's the integral of M
DX plus n dy and the curl is NX minus my
da so that's the other way to state it
so that's a really strange statement if
you think about it because the left-hand
side is a line integral okay so the way
we compute it is we take this expression
M DX plus n dy and we parameterize the
curve we express x and y in terms of
some variable t maybe or whatever you
want to call it and then you will do a
one variable integral over key this
right-hand side here it's a double
integral da so we do it the way that we
learned how to a couple of weeks ago you
take your region you slice it in the x
direction or in the Y direction and you
integrate DX dy after setting up the
bounds carefully or maybe in polar
coordinates rdrd theta let's see the way
in which you compute these things is
completely different this one on the
left hand side lives only on the curve
while the right hand side lives
everywhere in this region inside so here
x and y are related they live on the
curve here x and y are independent there
just are some bounds between them and of
course what you're integrating is
different here it's a line integral for
work here it's a double integral of some
function of x and y so
you know it's a very perplexing
statement at first but it's a very
powerful tool so we're going to try to
see you know how it works concretely
what it says what are the consequences
how we could convince ourselves that yes
this works and so on that's going to be
the topic for today any questions about
the statement first
nope okay oh yeah one remark sorry so
here it says counterclockwise what if I
have a curve that goes clockwise well
you could just take the negative and
integrate counterclockwise you know why
do I mean somehow why does the theorem
choose counterclockwise over clockwise
you know how does it know that it's
counterclockwise violent clockwise well
the answer is basically in our
convention for curl C we've said curl is
an X minus M Y and not we have a way
around and that's a convention as well
so somehow the two conventions match
with each other that's the best answer I
can give you so you know if you met
somebody from a different planet they
might have been theorem with the
opposite conventions with curves going
clockwise and Raquel define the other
way around I mean probably if you met an
alien then I'm not sure if you would be
discussing when sphere I'm first but
just in case you know
okay so that being said so there's a
warning here which is that this is only
for closed curbs okay so if I give you a
curve it's not closed and I tell you
well compute the line integral then you
know you have to do it by hand you have
to parameterize the curve oh if you
really don't like that line integral you
could close the path by adding some
other line integral to it and then
compute using greens theorem but you
can't use greens theorem directly if the
curve is not closed okay so let's do a
quick example so let's say that I give
you see the circle of radius 1 centered
at the point 2 comma 0 so you know it's
out here let's let's make our C and
let's say that I do it counterclockwise
so that it will you know it will match
with the statement of the theorem
and let's say that I want you to compute
the line integral along c of ye to a
minus X DX plus 1/2 of x squared minus e
to the minus X dy and you know that's a
kind of sadistic example but maybe I
will ask you to do that
so how would you do it directly well to
do it directly
you would have to parameterize this
curve so that would probably involve you
know setting x equals 2 plus cosine
theta y equals sine theta but you know
I'm using as parameter of the angle
around the circle it's like the unit
circle of the usual one but shifted by
two in the X direction and then I would
set DX equals minus sine theta D theta I
would set dy equals cos theta D theta
and I would substitute and I would
integrate from 0 to 2pi and I would
probably run into a bit of trouble
because I would have these e to the
minus X which would give me something
that I really don't want to integrate so
instead of doing that which looks pretty
much Ino doomed I'm going to tell me to
use greens theorem so using greens
theorem the way we'll do it is I will
instead compute a double integral so I
will
compute the double integral over the
region inside of curl F da so I should
say probably what F was so let's call
this M let's call this N and
then I will actually just choose
reformed in coordinates and X minus my
da and what is our here well our is the
disk in so of course it might not be
that Pleasant because we'll also have to
set up this double integral and for that
you know we'll have to figure out a way
to slice this region nicely we could do
it DX dy we could do it dy DX or maybe
we will want to actually make a change
of variables to first shift this to the
origin you know change X to X minus 2
and then switch to polar coordinates
well let's see what happens later ok so
what is so this is our so what is n sub
X well n sub X is X plus e to the minus
X minus what is M sub y e to the minus X
ok this is n X this is my DA well it
seems to simplify a bit right I will
just get the ball integral over R of x
da which looks at an a lot more pleasant
and of course I made up the example in
that way you know so that it simplifies
when you use greens theorem
but you know that gives you an example
where you can turn a really hard line
integral into an easier double integral
now how do we compute the double
integral oops well so one way will be to
set it up or let's actually be a bit
smarter and observe that this is
actually the area of the region R times
the x coordinate of its center of mass
right if I look at the definition of the
center of mass it's the average value of
x so it's 1 over the area times the
double integral of x da well possibly
with the density but here I'm taking
uniform density 1 and now I think I know
just by looking at the picture what we
have a center of mass of this circle
will be right I mean it will be right in
the middle so that is 2 if you want by
symmetry and the area of this guy is
just pi because it's a disk of radius 1
so I will just get 2 pi and of course if
you didn't see that then you could also
compute a double integral directly it's
a nice exercise but see here using
geometry helps you to actually
streamline the calculation ok any
questions
yes okay yes let me just repeat the last
part so I said we have to compute the
double integral of x da over this region
here which is a disc of radius 1
centered at this point is to 0 so
instead of setting up the integral you
know with bounds and integrating DX dy
or dy DX so in polar coordinates I'm
just going to say well let's remember
the definition of a center of mass it's
the average value of a function X in the
region so it's 1 over the area of the
region times the double integral of x da
if you look again at the definition of X
bar it's one other area double integral
of XD well maybe you know if there's a
density then it's one of our mass times
double integral of X density da but if
density is one then it just becomes this
so you know switching the area moving
the area at the other side I'll get
double integral of x da is the area of
the region times the x coordinate of the
center of mass the area of the region is
pi because it's a unit disk and the
center of mass is the center of a disk
so it's X bar is 2 and I get 2 pi ok now
I didn't actually have to do this in my
example today but I thought you know
that would be good way view it would
remind you of center of mass and all
that
okay any other questions nope okay so
let's see now that we've seen how to use
it in practice how to avoid calculating
a line integral if we don't want to
let's try to convince ourselves that
this theorem makes sense okay so well
let's start with an easy case where we
should be able to know the answer to
both sides so let's look at a special
case let's look at the case where curl F
is zero then well we'd like to conclude
that F is conservative that's what we've
said well let's see what happens
so when theorem says that I have a
closed curve then the line integral of F
is equal to the double integral of curl
on the region inside and if a curl is
zero then I will be integrating 0 I will
get 0 ok so this is actually how you
prove that if your vector field has curl
0 when it's conservative
okay so in particular if you have a
vector field that's defined everywhere
in the plane then you take any closed
curve well you will get that the line
integral will be zero
strictly speaking that will only work
here if the curve goes counterclockwise
but otherwise you know just look at the
various loops that it makes and orient
each of them counterclockwise and some
things together so let me state that
again
so
okay so a consequence of greens theorem
is that if F is defined everywhere in
the plane and the curl of F is zero
everywhere then F is conservative and so
this actually is the input we needed to
justify our criterion you know the test
that we saw last time saying well to
check if something is a gradient field
if it's conservative we just have to
compute the curl and check whether it's
zero okay so how do we prove that
now carefully well you just take a
closed curve in the plane you switch the
orientation if needed so that it becomes
counterclockwise and then you look at
the region inside and then you know that
the line integral will be equal to the
double integral of curl which is the
double integral of zero therefore that
zero but see okay so now let's say that
we try to do that for a vector field
that was on your problem set that was
not defined at the origin you know so if
you've done the problem set and found
the same answers that I did then you
will have found that this vector field
had curl zero everywhere but still it
wasn't conservative because if you went
around the unit circle then you got a
line integral that was 2pi or if you
compare the two halves you got different
answers for two pipes that go from the
same point to the same point so you know
it fails this property but that's
because it's not defined everywhere so
what goes wrong with this argument well
if I take the vector field that was on
the problem set
and if I do things you know say that I
look at the unit circle that's a closed
curve so I would like to use greens
theorem
Vence theorem would tell me the line
integral along this loop is equal to the
double integral of curl of this region
here the unit disk and of course the
curl is zero
well except at the origin at the origin
the vector field is not defined you
cannot take the derivatives and the curl
is not defined and somehow that messes
things up you cannot apply greens
theorem to the vector field so you
cannot apply greens theorem to the
vector field on problem set eight
problem two when C encloses the origin
and so that's why this guy even though
it has curl zero is not conservative you
know there's no contradiction and
somehow you have to imagine that well
the curl here is it's really not defined
but somehow it becomes infinite so that
when you do the double integral you
actually get two pi instead of zero I
mean that doesn't make any sense of
course but that's one way to think about
it
okay any questions yes well so actually
it's not defined see because the curve
would be called zero everywhere else so
if a curve was well defined at the
origin you know you would try to then
take the double integral well no matter
what value you put for a function you
know if you have a function that's zero
everywhere except at the origin and some
other value at the origin the integral
is still 0 so it's worse than that it
doesn't have it's not only that you
can't compute it it's really that it's
not defined okay anyway that's you know
like a slightly pathological example I
mean yes well we wouldn't be able to
because the curl is not defined at the
origin so you can't actually integrate
it okay so that's that's the problem I
mean if you try to integrate you know
we've said everywhere where it's defined
the curl is zero so what you would be
integrating would be zero but that
doesn't work because at the origin it's
not defined yes
so if you take a curve that makes a
figure eight then indeed my probe over
various folds so I kind of try to you
you know it's not actually correct so if
the curve does a figure eight then what
you would do is you would actually cut
it into its two halves and for each of
them you will apply greens theorem and
then you would still get that you know
if the curl is zero then this line
integral is zero that one is also 0 so
that's immiscible okay
small details that you don't really need
to worry too much about but indeed if
you want to be careful with details man
my proof is not quite complete but the
conclusion is still true okay let's move
on so I want to tell you how to prove
greens theorem because you know it's
such a strange formula that you know
where can it come from possibly I mean
so let me remind you first of all the
statement we want to prove is that the
line integral along a closed curve of M
DX plus n dy is equal to the double
integral of a region inside of NX minus
my da and you know let's simplify our
lives a bit by proving easier statements
so actually the first observation will
actually prove something easier namely
that the line integral let's see of MDX
along a closed curve is equal to the
double integral over the region inside
of minus M sub y da okay so that's the
special case
where n is where you have only an X
component for your vector field now why
is that good enough well the claim is if
I can prove this I claim you will be
able to do the same thing to prove the
other case where there's only a Y
component and then if you add them
together you'll get the general case so
let me explain
okay
so a similar argument which I will not
do to save time will show so it will be
just the same thing but switching the
roles of X and y that if I integrate
along a closed curve and UI then I'll
get four double integral of sine n sub X
da and so now if I have proved these two
formulas separately then if you sum them
together
we'll get the correct statement but let
me not write it we get greens theorem
okay so we've simplified simplify that
task a little bit we'll just be trying
to prove the case where there's only an
X component so let's do it well we have
another problem which is the region that
we were looking at the curve that we're
looking at might be very complicated you
know if I give you let's say I give you
I don't know a curve that does something
like this well you know it will be kind
of tricky to set up a double integral
over the region inside so maybe we first
want to look at curves that are simpler
you know that will actually allow us to
set up the double integral easily so the
second observation so that was the first
observation the second observation is
that we can decompose R into simpler
regions
so what do I mean by that well let's say
that I have you know a region and I'm
going to cut it into two so I will have
r1 and r2 and then of course I need to
have the curves that go around them so I
had my initial curve C was going around
everybody they have curves c1 that goes
around our one and C two goes around our
two okay so what I would like to say is
if we can prove that the statement is
true so let's see for c1 and also for c2
then I claim we can prove the statement
for see how do we do that well we just
add these two equality's together okay
why does that work there's something
fishy going on because c1 and c2 have
this piece here in the middle that's
nothing that's not very in C so if you
add the line integral along c1 and c2
you get you know these unwanted pieces
but the good news is actually you go
twice for that edge in the middle C it
appears once in c1 going up and once in
the c2 going down so in fact when you
will do the work you know when you will
send the work you will add these two
guys together they will cancel okay so
the line integral along c will be then
it will be the sum of all integrals on
c1 and c2 and that will equal therefore
the double integral over r1 plus the
double integral over R which is the
double integral over R of negative my
okay and the reason for this equality
here is because we go twice pull the
inner part what do not see for the
boundary well we go twice along the
boundary between r1 and r2 with opposite
orientations so the extra things cancel
out okay so that means I just need to
look at you know smaller pieces if that
makes my life easier so now what will
make my life easy well let's say that I
have you know curve like that well I
guess I should really draw a pumpkin or
something like that because it would be
more seasonal but okay well I don't
really know how to draw pumpkins so
okay so I'm going to you know what I
will do is I will cut this into smaller
regions for which I have a well-defined
lower and upper boundary so that I will
be able to set up a double integral dy
DX easily so a region like this I will
actually cut it here here and here
into five smaller pieces so that each
small piece will let me set up the
double integral dy DX
okay so we'll cut our into what I will
call vertically simple regions so what's
a vertically simple region that's a
region that's given by looking at X
between a and B for some values of a and
B and for each value of x y is between
some function of X and some other
function of X okay so for example this
guy is vertically simple C X ones from
this value of x to that value of x and
for each X Y goes between this value to
that value and same with each of these
okay so now we are down to the main step
that we have to do which is to prove
this identity if C is so if if R is
vertically simple and C is the boundary
of our going counterclockwise okay so
let's look at how we would do it so we
say it vertically simple region looks
like X goes between a and B and Y goes
between two values that are given by
functions of X okay so this is y equals
F 2 of X this is y equals F 1 of X this
is a this is B our region is this thing
in here
so let's compute both sides and when I
say compute of course we will not get
numbers because we don't know what M is
we don't know what f1 and f2 are but I
claim we should be able to simplify
things a bit so let's start with the
line integral how do i compute the line
integral along this curve that goes all
around here well it looks like there
will be four pieces ok so we actually
have four things to compute C 1 C 2 C 3
and C 4
well let's start with c1 so if we
integrate on c1 MDX how do we do that
well we know that an c1 y is given by
your function of X so we can just get
rid of Y and express everything in terms
of in terms of X okay so we know Y is f1
of X and X goes from A to B so that will
be the integral from A to B of well I
have to take the function M so you know
M depends normally on x and y maybe I
should put x and y here and then I will
plug y equals f1 of X DX and then I have
a single variable integral and that's
what I have to compute of course I
cannot compute it here because I don't
know what this is so it has to stay this
way ok next one the integral along c2
well let's think for a second on c2 x
equals B it's constant so DX is 0 and
you know you would integrate actually of
a variable Y but well we don't have a y
component C this is the reason why we
made the first observation we got rid of
the other term because it simplifies our
life here so we just get 0 ok just
looking quickly ahead there's another
one that will be 0 as well right
which one yeah c4 so gives me 0
what about c3
well CFA will look a lot like c1 okay so
we're going to use the same kind of
thing that we did with c1
okay so I don't see three well let's see
so on c3 y is a function of X again and
so we're using as our variable X but now
X goes down from B to a so it will be
the integral from B to a of M of X and
f2 of X DX now if you prefer that's
negative integral from A to B of M of X
and f2 of X DX okay so now if I sum all
these pieces together I get that the
line integral along the closed curve is
the integral from A to B of M X f1 of X
DX
minus the integral from A to B of M of x
f2 of X DX so that's the left-hand side
next I should try to look at my double
integral and see if I can make it equal
to that so let's look at the other guy
double integral over R of negative my da
well first I'll take the minus sign out
will make my life a little bit easier
and second so I said I will try to set
this up in the way that's the most
efficient and my choice of this kind of
region means that it's easier to set up
dy/dx right so if I set it up dy/dx then
I know for a given value of x Y goes on
f1 of X to F 2 of X and X goes from A to
B right is that ok with everyone ok so
now if I compute the inner integral well
what do I get if I integrate
partial and partial Y with respect to Y
and get em back ok so
so I will get em at the point X F 2 of X
minus M at the point X F 1 of X and so
this becomes the integral from A to B I
guess that was a minus sign of M of X F
2 of X minus M of X F 1 of X DX
and so that's the same as up there so
that's the end of the proof because
we've checked that for this special case
when we have only an X component and a
vertically simple region things work
then we can remove the assumption that
things are vertically simple using this
second observation we can adjust you
know glue various pieces together and
prove it for any region then we do the
same thing with the y component that's
the first observation when we add the
things together we get greens theorem in
its full generality
okay so let me finish with a cool
example
so there's one place in real life we are
greens fear I'm used to be extremely
useful I say used to because computers
have actually made that obsolete but so
let me show you the picture of this
device this is called a plan emitter and
what it does okay
and what it does is it measures areas so
it used to be that when you you know
when you were an experimental scientist
you would you know run your chemical or
biological experiment or whatever and
you would have all of these recording
devices and the data would go well not
unto a floppy disk or hard disk or
whatever because you didn't have those
at the time didn't have a computer in
your lab they would go into a piece of
graph paper notes you'd have your graph
paper and you would have you know some
curve on it and very often you wanted to
know what's the total amount of product
that you have synthesized or whatever
question might be it might relate with
you know the area under your curve so
you'd say oh that's easy let's just
integrate well except you don't have a
function you can put that into your
calculator the next thing you could do
is well let's count the little squares
but you know if you've seen a piece of
graph paper that's kind of
time-consuming so people invented these
things called blend emitters where so
it's something where there's a really
heavy thing they set at one corner and
there's a lot of dials and gauges and
everything and there's one arm that you
move and so what you do is you take even
moving arm and you just slide it all
around your curve and you look at one of
the dials and suddenly what comes you
know as you go around it gives you
complete garbage but when you come back
here that they also need gives you the
value of the array of this region so how
does it work you know this gadget never
knows about the region inside
you don't take it all over here you only
take it along the curve so what it does
actually is it computes a line integral
okay so you know it has the system of
wheels and everything that compute for
you the line integral along c of well
depends on the model but some of them
compute the line integral of x dy some
of them compute different line integrals
but they compute some line integral okay
and now if you apply greens theorem you
see that when you have a
counterclockwise curve this will be just
the area of the region inside and so
that's you know that's how it works I
mean of course now you use a computer
and it does the sense yes that costs
several thousand dollars possibly more
so that's why I didn't bring one